F
YOUR OWN STATE, TEXAS.
THAT IS A FAIR QUESTION.
KELSEY COVERED HIS PRO-AMERICAN,
LIFELONG DEMOCRAT, ROY IS
GRATEFUL TO HAVE HER JOIN US
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
IF YOU WERE IN THE HOUSE STILL,
YOU LEFT AFTER THE END OF LAST
CYCLE, BUT IF YOU ARE STILL
THERE, I DON'T THINK HE WOULD BE
ABLE TO SEE A SINGLE WORD
WITHOUT BEING DENOUNCED AS
PRO-RUSSIA.
>> WHICH IS A PROBLEM FOR
DEMOCRACY.
I THINK THE REAL QUESTION HERE,
TUCKER, THAT WE ARE ALL ASKING
THESE LEADERS IN WASHINGTON IS,
WHAT IS THE RUSH?
WHY ARE OUR POLITICAL LEADERS
FROM BOTH PARTIES RUSHING THIS
THROUGH WITHOUT GIVING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT WHAT IS IN
THE BILL AND EXAMINE WHAT THE
COST WILL BE TO US, NOT JUST
TODAY WITH THIS BILL, BUT WITH
THE NEXT ROUND OF $40 BILLION OR
WHATEVER BILLIONS THEY WILL ASK
FOR IN THE NEXT ROUND AND THE
NEXT ROUND, AND THE NEXT ROUND.
THERE IS NO IMMINENT THREAT TO
THE SAFETY AND SECURITY AND
FREEDOM OF THE UNITED STATES
COMING TO US FROM RUSSIA.
IN FACT, THERE IS NO IMMINENT
THREAT OR EVEN LONG-TERM THREAT
OF RUSSIA INVADING FINLAND OR
SWEDEN.
RUSSIA CAN BARELY HOLD ON TO A
VERY SMALL SLIVER OF UKRAINE
RIGHT NOW.
AS THESE LEADERS AGAIN, WHAT IS
THE RUSH?
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS FAILED
TO CLEARLY DEFINE ANY OBJECTIVES
IN THIS PROXY WAR ON UKRAINE BUT
THEY FAILED TO DEFINE WHAT
WINNING LOOKS LIKE, SO CLEARLY
THERE IS NO END IN SIGHT WITHOUT
THAT BEING DEFINED.
WE CAN LOOK AT AFGHANISTAN, VERY
RECENT EXAMPLES OF WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE THAT CLEARLY
DEFINED MISSION.
SO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WERE
STRUGGLING WITH HIGH INFLATION,
BASIC NECESSITIES THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO LIVE, COSTS INCREASING,
AND YET WITH THIS $40 BILLION OF
FUNDING AND WHAT WILL COME NEXT
AND NEXT AND NEXT, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DESERVE TO KNOW WHAT THIS
WILL COST US FINANCIALLY, WHAT
IT WILL COST OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY WITH THE INCREASED
POTENTIAL OF A NUCLEAR CONFLICT
IF THIS IS ALLOWED TO CONTINUE.
SPEAK OF THE MORE I THINK ABOUT
IT, THE MORE GOLF OR EYE PATCH
McCAIN TO ATTACK MOMS WHO ARE
WORRIED ABOUT BABY FORMULA AS
"PRO-RUSSIA."
THAT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
OUTRAGEOUS THINGS I'VE EVER
HEARD.
WHY NOT JUST ANSWER THE
QUESTION?
WHY THE ATTACKS?
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> IT TELLS YOU THEY DON'T
REALLY WANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO KNOW WHAT IS IN THIS BILL AND
WHAT WILL COME NEXT AND WHAT IT
WILL TRULY COST US, NOT JUST A
FEW OF US, BUT ALL OF US AS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TODAY AND WHAT
APPEARS TO BE, IF WE CONTINUE
DOWN THIS PATH, FOR THE
LONG TERM TO COME.
RESORTING TO NAME-CALLING AND
SMEARING, CLEARLY TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: YOU'VE BEEN SMEARED
SINCE DAY ONE, YOU'VE NEVER LOST
HER COMPOSURE OR MOVED OFF
COURSE, AND I DEFINITELY ADMIRE
THE WAY YOU'VE HANDLED T